also we're having some economic problems
have you heard about that have you tried
to get gas recently have you noticed
about inflation are you trying to build
a house or get any raw materials and two
by fours cost 10 times what they did
literally a year and a half ago well
desantis is also trying to figure out
well how can we protect ourselves while
the federal government does all sorts of
crazy things
related to inflation and now the biden
administration is talking about a
digital dollar which kind of sounds cool
because that has something to do with
crypto and bitcoin or something but uh
desantis can see through the curtain
and there's a difference between a
decentralized digital currency
cryptocurrency like a bitcoin and what
some are talking about doing at the
federal level to convert u.s dollars
into basically a digital currency i
think there's a lot of hazards with that
when that's centrally controlled i worry
about the amount of power that that
would give
someone in a central authority to
basically be able to shut off access to
purchasing certain goods you know we'd
be in unchartered territories and we've
seen how some of these financial
institutions acting at the behest of
government can cut people off can you
imagine
if the federal government actually
controlled whether you could even go in
so i know biden issued an executive
order i'm very concerned about that but
i think it's something that we need to
be watching
it's the fundamental difference between
decentralization and centralization what
what the left seems to want what the
communists i mean there's just no point
calling them anything else the democrats
they're democrats i don't know what
makes them democrats anymore with the
democrats socialists whatever they are
what they want is a centralized system
because in a centralized system somebody
makes the decision and they're above you
they're the elites they're above you and
they tell you how to live
what freedom loving people want is
exactly what rhonda santa said right
there which is you want a decentralized
system because that's bottom up that
allows people to exchange good goods and
services with each other hopefully for
the benefit of both and from that you
can build not only it starts with
individuals but then you can hopefully
build families and communities and all
of those things and then states and
everything else so when biden says that
we want perhaps in the united states a
digital dollar it sort of sounds right
it's like oh well there's something
about bitcoin and crypto and digital
dollar it sounds right but as desantis
correctly points out if it's centralized
that means they can just cut you off at
any moment that means they can shut down
your wallet at any moment remember what
happened in canada a few weeks ago when
they were going after
the the bank accounts of the truckers
think how dangerous it would be if we
have a digital dollar and then you
protest the government and then all the
government has to do some some
government lackey bureaucrat
adios amigo your money is gone